[Music]
dude james franco's fidel castro i'm
excited are you excited no he is cuban
he's white cuban that's what i read
what can you look that up his father was
of portuguese and swedish ancestry and
his mother is jewish oh not even close i
just can't imagine him doing a cuban
accent this is gonna go
so bad dude it's gonna it's gonna be
it's gonna be like uh an entourage when
vince played um pablo escobar yeah
behind the legend
was the man
vincent chase
medellin
it's gonna be like that yeah no this is
sick i'm glad hollywood still does this
[ __ ] man liam neeson as fidel castro
people have said they look the same for
years hmm yeah i mean if you're gonna
cast someone who doesn't i mean you
might
oh
why wouldn't you go with the highest
caliber non-cuban actor yeah james
[ __ ] franco yeah he's not that good
of an actor is he i don't think his is
like that yeah it's still gonna be his
teeth behind that mustache
you know what i mean like you're gonna
like get the vibe of his face yeah yeah
yeah and you're gonna rule like you're
gonna think it's just like a pineapple
express exactly cut away
yeah liam neeson that's i mean if you're
gonna go with someone non-cuban yeah
yeah go all the way yeah and have liam
neeson use his regular voice yeah i mean
i guess people were because
i don't know
what i don't [ __ ] know what were you
about to say something about like
because i was just reading like people
were in the comments like no but fidel
castro is white cuban so it's okay for a
white person to play but i just thought
i don't know got it even i don't think
that
that's not a valid argument i know i
yeah i don't know i'm just it's just
like a weird acrobat
no no he's white what the [ __ ] is white
cuban
like i don't know i mean i okay so i
know like in certain countries where
there's like a lot of um no no what's
the term i'm looking for like like the
philippines the philippines has a ton of
different like influences like in terms
of like ethnicity because different
groups like conquered or like i was the
term i'm looking for colonized yeah geez
like colonized there so you know like in
the philippines there's like four major
categories of like appearance right so
even then i just feel like it's a weird
acrobat to be like no no he comes from
like the european part of of cuba yeah
so like it's fine if it's james franco
like it's just a weird leaf
yeah to make the connection no dude he's
white cuban it's totally fine if it's
michael keaton yeah
it's the same [ __ ] i was just laughing
because i looked at the topic stock and
it says cody's race on there yeah
referring to my race and i wrote that i
was like
you should tell him you're gonna replace
james
people were saying i'm also white yeah
that's i don't know why that's on there
but yeah i'm cody's race just want to
clarify also white
that'd be [ __ ] so funny cody co
casted as fidel castro
like what the [ __ ] he doesn't even know
what
no it's fine fidel castro is white cuban
isn't this the guy that said white cuban
in his podcast
you